foreign
[Music]
let's talk about what a point guard is
Excellence the leader on the floor
the coach for the coach
[Music]
let's Elevate the title to point guards
the title that very few have ever
attained I'm talking about Dwayne Pearl
Washington AKA Pac-Man and I'll talk
about what
Sam God
Kenny Anderson
future Speedy boom Professor come on now
all the point guards I just mentioned
were birthed here on the hollow asphalt
of New York City
[Music]
but let's go beyond
Puerto Rico the island of Enchantment
and recognize the point guards
[Music]
there's three players who are kind of
like Los Tres Reyes it's a holiday in
Puerto Rico you understand they already
legendary on the island one had his
number retired on the national team he
goes by the name of scalito
another recently retired as an NBA
champion his name JJ Maria
and the last but not least
the young one in the mix
who's about to create waves and havoc
and to NBA this upcoming season he goes
by the name of Jose Alvarado
and this is the point guards the Puerto
Rico
Point loss
the end result I think nobody believed
you know the way it went down we
scrimmage USA at that summer before the
Olympics about three to four times and
the one thing that Larry Brown that was
the coach for that team so they asked us
to play you know man-to-man throughout
the whole scrimmages that we had so our
coaching staff was like we're gonna play
zone the whole game
you know so we had an advantage as far
as preparation when it came down to
playing USA but it was an amazing moment
for Puerto Rico basketball for the
history of basketball in our Island to
this day they celebrate that day like
it's a birthday it was a team effort
everybody obviously did their part for
us to be able to accomplish what we did
and we're in the history books man I'm
truly honored and blessed to be a part
of that moment we played with a lot of
respect a lot of dignity because I you
know the fan base that we have in Puerto
Rico is not only in the island it's all
around the world Puerto Ricans they come
out of everywhere you know yeah and we
got cousins and grandparents and you
know Brothers everywhere so it's truly
an honor to to just represent the island
the way we do so JJ
this is one of my favorite moments in
NBA history I'm going to keep 100 with
you because and it's also historic not
just for the league but also for the
franchise that you represented for so
many years the Dallas Mavericks in 2011
during the finals and game four the
coaching staff decides to change the
starting lineup and insert you that's
crazy I mean that might happen in the
middle of the Season rare for the
playoffs but unheard of for the finals
and the crazy thing is after you start
it the Mavs didn't lose again y'all want
three in a row and took the chip where
were you
when the coach
shared with you that you're starting
yeah I was driving home from practice
the day before the the game and Coach
calls me and sometimes hey we're going
to start you tomorrow we're going to
change things up and all we want you to
do is grab the ball and attack the pain
try to find Dirk early like I go home
and I tell my parents yo I'm starting
tomorrow and the NBA Finals so I had to
find a way to stay as relaxed as
possible but it worked out so it was a
great move by coach it was not easy to
make that move but he made it and it
worked out for us
so Jose like
do something that's a little cuckoo you
know like if I was a coach
you would be driving me crazy most
people try to steal from behind in the
front court on a fast break
you do it in the backcourt on the
inbound or off of a change of possession
[Music]
[Applause]
what were the sidelines what were your
teammates what were your coaches telling
you like I'm sure they didn't approve
I mean it just happened actually when I
was around like seventh grades eighth
grade but I got in trouble for it for a
while you know people tell me you would
not make any team going that my college
post was like if you do that I'm subbing
you out so I'm like and then the NBA
coach monkey brain you really never said
nothing I think he didn't know I was
doing that first I think he was lost too
I think he was just looking up the floor
so he couldn't really say nothing at the
time but when I did do it I was already
the ball was stolen so he he liked it he
never told me nothing never turned
around the Bible trying to figure out
and this is what Alvarado does
[Applause]
he did it in Puerto Rico and cost us a
three no yeah
yeah one thing right here I think I
would have got caught up in jail calling
would have thought he was cool you know
he wanna you wanna do a fancy things
the same ones